on this Sunday night support for Nova
Scotia one week after the mass killing
there are no words that can adequately
express the sense of grief but can the
survivors ever move on from this grief
felt across Canada the losses for potato
farmers during kovat 19 the piles of
produce with nowhere to go
a view from the frontlines of the
pandemic this is what I signed up for we
go inside a hospital to meet the health
care workers trying to protect Canadians
Plus packing on the pandemic pounds
might be time to physically distance
from the fridge
[Music]
global national with Robin Gil
good evening thank you for joining us we
begin tonight in Nova Scotia where the
community is trying to heal one week
after a tragedy that has shaken the
nation from coast to coast to coast
there's an outpouring of support and
tributes to the 22 victims killed in a
senseless attack but as Ross Lord
reports there may never be a way to
fully recover from the trauma of losing
so many innocent lives everyone wants to
help ease the pain but sometimes lining
up gestures of support with people's
ability to receive them can be difficult
it seems some friends and family members
of the victims did not watch Friday's
stirring virtual vigil in there
devastated condition grief counselors
see people in the string of small
communities hardest hit by the massacre
are only now starting to grieve there
are no words that can adequately express
the sense of grief and loss this pastor
says some parishioners are questioning
their faith he says many are turning
toward the church we have others that
are tuning in these days because people
are more and more interested in in in
what the the gospel the hope of the
gospel has to offer them for their lives
in these times of great need as
investigators continue searching for a
motive there's a growing call for a
public inquiry it would examine what
happened and how the gunman was able to
slip past our CMP and use his Mountie
disguise at mock RCMP Cruiser to
continue his killing spree to ensure
that the earth CPR being a public
enquiry could also explore why the RCMP
didn't initiate an emergency alert and
instead relied on Twitter messages a
decision some friends and families say
might have cost lives
Nick Beaton says his wife nurse Kristin
Beaton would have stayed home had she
been fully aware of the danger the
tributes continue runner chris harding
ran 22 kilometers to honor the victims
shouting the names of each one to start
each kilometer counselors say more
creative methods may be required to help
grieving communities adapt Ross Lord
Global News Halifax in Montreal an 11
year old girl is dead and her little
sister is in hospital after being
stabbed police were called to a home
yesterday evening both girls were rushed
to hospital in critical condition
their 34 old mother was also taken to
hospital with injuries she's now been
arrested and is facing charges the 11
year old died of her injuries last night
her five-year-old sister is
in stable condition to the Cova 19
crisis now the pandemic has affected
every aspect of our lives including the
food sector there isn't a food shortage
in some cases there's too much of it
producers in this country from meat and
seafood processors to potato farmers are
struggling and as David Aken reports
some of that food is just going to get
wasted
Canada loves its french fries but
Canadians prefer to eat their fries in
restaurants and with restaurants closed
or only doing takeout Canadians are just
not eating fries like they used to
pre-pandemic
that's a big problem for Canada's potato
farmers who still have millions of
pounds of potatoes from last year's crop
that they have not yet sold
that's huge like to our operation it
will be over half hour just because the
two million dollars not realized Owen
has 19 million pounds of potatoes stored
in his farm all of which would have been
turned into french fries but with the
restaurant trade all but shut down the
freezers at French fry processors are
full they don't need any more potatoes
meanwhile what to do about this year's
crop potatoes are typically planted
right about now in early spring we're
gonna plant probably 15% less already
that's what their processors are told us
to do so but you know there's no
guarantee there doesn't turn around
really and while Canada has too many
potatoes there could soon be shortages
of beef pork and possibly seafood a
meatpacking plant in High River Alberta
that accounts for about 40 percent of
Canada's beef has been shut after too
many workers got sick with kovin 19
other meat packers are also struggling
to manage kovat 19 outbreaks on Monday a
pork processing plant near Kitchener
Ontario one that produces about one
third of the federally inspected pork in
that province is set to close for a week
as plant owners deal with a covin 19
outbreak there meanwhile harvesters of
fish and shellfish say they need urgent
help to keep production levels up
harvesters are certainly interested in
in fishing but they got to do it safely
and right now to really be unsure about
if it can be profitable at all now now
experts say Canada still has plenty of
food but they also caution that these
supply chain problems could cause price
spikes and shortages of some products
David Aitken Global News Ottawa
let's take a look at the cove at 19
numbers across the country right now
more than 46,000 Canadians have tested
positive for the virus more than 2500
people have died all publicly funded
schools in Ontario will remain closed
until at least the end of May they were
scheduled to open next week but the
provinces Education Minister had to
change policy based on advice from
medical experts we're going to ensure
that safety remains our Paramount
priority which is why we're providing an
additional month extension for us to
work with dr. Williams the command table
to make sure we get this right to make
sure that ultimately the students and
staff when they return can do so with
absolute confidence it is safe to do so
the school closures and that province
could be extended again meanwhile
tomorrow québec's premier
is expected to unveil that provinces
plan for allowing students to return to
class Health Canada has issued a warning
about the use of certain anti malarial
drugs to treat Cova 19 the agency says
chloroquine and hydroxychloroquine can
have serious side effects and should
only be used under the supervision of a
physician
Health Canada issued this statement out
of concern people are directly buying
the drugs to treat or prevent kovat 19
US President Donald Trump has touted
hydroxychloroquine as a game-changer it
is being studied but early research
found it was of no benefit in the Cova
19 fight in the u.s. some states are
starting to ease Cova 19 restrictions
Georgia South Carolina Oklahoma and
Alaska are all allowing some businesses
to reopen Colorado Minnesota Montana
Iowa and Tennessee will begin easing
restrictions this week stay at home
orders for more than a dozen states are
slated to expire by the end of the month
all of this is happening against the
advice of health experts as Jennifer
Johnson explains they believe the key to
reopening the economy safely is testing
with no social distancing and no masks
protesters across America are still
sending out their message loud and clear
they fear personal bankruptcy more than
cope in nineteen I decided to come out
today because I want a rally for freedom
over fear and the entire country for
this and it's just up sorry we're losing
our freedom in Texas Dallas salon owner
Shelley Luther tore up a police citation
she got after accepting customers the
governor doesn't plan to reopen
non-essential businesses until April
30th I have rights you have rights to
feed your children and make income
federal health officials are trying to
put the brakes on states reopening too
soon and say social distancing measures
should continue through the summer they
say new testing technology is needed to
ensure everyone's safety we have to have
a breakthrough innovation and testing we
have to be able to detect antigen rather
than constantly expect the actual live
by
but dr. Burke says those tests could be
months away along with States the
Pentagon says it needs additional tests
for those in national security including
military aboard soon to be deployed
aircraft carriers defense leaders hope
to increase testing from 7,000 a day to
60,000 by June meanwhile governors are
now battling a new problem an uptick in
calls to poison control centers after US
President Donald Trump made comments
about injecting disinfectants into the
body as a treatment for cope in nineteen
when the person with the most powerful
position on the planet is encouraging
people think about disinfectants whether
it was serious or not people listened
and so we have seen an increase in
numbers of people calling poison control
health officials are again warning
people there is still no proven
treatment or cure for koban 19 Jennifer
Johnson Global News Washington
outside the US for keeping an eye on
regions for the number of new cases is
increasing significantly Russia has
among the highest number of new cases
with more than 6300 reported today a
single day record that brings the
country's total to at least eighty
thousand Brazil also had its highest
number of new cases yesterday about
5,500 it has the most confirmed cases in
Latin America with more than fifty nine
thousand people infected another country
to watch in that region is Ecuador it
has more than 22,000 confirmed cases
half of those reportedly on Friday alone
testing and reporting in that country is
spotty and even the country's president
warns the situation is far worse than it
appears over 20,000 people have now died
from kovat 19 in the United Kingdom with
400 deaths reported in the last 24 hours
the total cases of Cova 19 in that
country have now passed a hundred and
fifty-two thousand Prime Minister Boris
Johnson was one of those cases
he's now fully recovered and is
returning to work tomorrow
Johnson was out of action for more than
three weeks he spent a week in hospital
three of those nights in intensive care
all patients in the Chinese city of
Wuhan work overnight
was first discovered have now all left
hospital after recovering health
officials in Wuhan say that for the
first time there is no one suffering
from Cova 19 in its hospitals the city
recorded more than 46,000 cases of Coppa
19 more than 3800 people reportedly died
tonight there is international intrigue
over the fate of North Korea's leader
according to reports out of Japan Kim
jong-un is in a vegetative state US
intelligence claims the dictator could
be dead or in critical condition after
heart surgery that went wrong
China has since sent a team of doctors
to North Korea South Korea says Kim is
alive and well in a rural area of the
rogue state new satellite photos show a
train likely belonging to Kim has been
parked at a resort town since April 21st
The Dictator hasn't been seen for at
least two weeks and he missed the
celebration of his grandfather's
birthday this Bud's for the Blues coming
up how advertisers now have to get the
tone right or risk sounding
opportunistic
and we're going to show the world what
great Canadian fire power is all about
and how resilient and how strong how
much love we have tonight if Canada's
turned to honor our frontline health
care workers with a star-studded show
stronger together we'll be the biggest
multi-platform broadcast in Canadian
history it will unite this country's
biggest celebrities proceeds will
support Canada's food banks the show
will be broadcast on a hundred and
twenty platforms including right here on
global starting at 6:30 if you've been
spending a lot more time in front of the
TV these days you may have noticed a
shift in advertising with kovat 19
lockdowns marketing campaigns had to be
rewritten overnight here's Mike delay
now on the struggle to get the message
right
by the time Canadians were being told to
shut their doors and isolate Tim Hortons
marketing team was already turning their
massive advertising ship around
everything that had been planned was now
out the window our drive throughs are
here for you
replaced by sound advice from the drive
through you can use an example of a
natural disaster when the hurricane hits
nobody does any advertising but the
hurricane passes in two or three days
the problem is this hurricane is taking
12 weeks to pass by can we just sit in a
vacuum for 12 weeks no this Bud's for
the Blues the one consistent message
across all brands is support for
frontline workers and those who've lost
so much because of kovat 19
this Bud's for the home team but what's
really interesting is the number of
companies that are putting out ads
merely to keep their brands active you
wouldn't know this was an uber ad until
the end when the company gives things
for people not calling them a similar
sentiment we found from car
manufacturers whose business has dried
up urging customers to stay home but
then you have all those ads companies
have scrambled to pull KFC has been
using it's finger-licking good slogan
since the 1950s but in 2020 licking your
fingers is a big no-no and who would
have predicted so many people would be
working from home Coors Light and it's
official beer of working remotely
campaign would suggest Coors had an
inkling except those ads which are no
longer running were produced months ago
and were aimed at us college basketball
fans but separated we are today more
United than ever
tone is everything right now no company
wants to look insensitive or even worse
opportunistic it's a super fine balance
between you know trying to use this for
commercial gain versus trying to just
stay in touch with Canadians are you
sure that we're here for Canadians I
think is one thing versus trying to you
know squeeze more commercial value out
of people at a time like that I think
that's where you cross the line and
don't expect that to change anytime soon
at least not as long as we're in
isolation microlight Global News Toronto
still ahead we take you behind the
scenes to show you how healthcare
workers are fighting the kovat 19
across the country many hospitals have
been designated to specifically treat
Kovan 19 patients for most of us the
true scope of what's happening behind
the scenes is hard to gauge Global sir
McDonald spent the day inside a PC
Hospital showing the grave risk health
care workers face every single day
inside what is typically the provinces
busiest emergency departments the
silence is striking
it's a heightened anxiety definitely but
it's it's changed our intake of people
because we've told the people to stay
away for those who simply can't the
first point of contact is a registered
nurse like Lisa rice for the most part
this is what I signed up for this is my
job this is what I do it's it's fine
you'll be asked if you have any symptoms
we were invited in size by freezer
health its leader no stranger to
combating communicable diseases and past
pandemics we've never had this level of
measures that have been put in place
when you see some of the health systems
that are supposedly comparable to our
health systems and they're not coping
very well it does make you really take a
serious attention to how we're preparing
for this pandemic health systems like
Italy's where the kovat 19 wave crashed
with little warning and devastating
consequences as sort of information came
out of Italy it radically changed our
approach the approach to treating
patients is changing just as rapidly as
the data starts in the lungs without a
doubt but the immune systems that gets
ramped up to fight the virus can also
damage the body you know the muscle
aches and pains that a lot of people
complain of early in the disease or it
probably at least in some way the immune
system the inflammation affecting the
muscles and deciding which patients need
one of these can present its own
challenges the reality is when we talk
about
Oh care dying is not the worst possible
thing that can happen to people the
ventilator is not harmless so we we have
a big plastic tube that goes through the
vocal cord so people can't talk and they
choke with every breath Fiona McLeod's
and her colleagues are all too familiar
with one of the compounded cruel teas of
the novel coronavirus a lot of our
patients are unfortunately on
ventilators and can't speak to us but
they can listen recently we had a nurse
who was in the room with the patient
holding the patient's hand had the
family on speaker and assured the family
that the patient could hear them that
they knew that they were there are you
worried about contracting over yourself
yeah I think everybody is sometimes the
hand a patient holds isn't always
familiar in a pandemic Sarah McDonald
Global News Surrey BC up next the
quarantine 19 how do you avoid too much
self-indulgence in self isolation
[Music]
you
with stay-at-home orders in place it's
easy to find an excuse to wander into
the kitchen where the recipe for packing
on the pounds lurks in every cupboard
tonight Reggie Cecchini looks at ways to
watch your waistline and help flatten
your curves during the pandemic
isolation and Quarantine have now become
a new normal for most of the world and
while practicing social distancing is
now helping to slow the spread the more
time we spend indoors leads to more time
spent in front of open doors we likely
will be snacking more often when we are
working from home that's just because we
have easier access to our kitchen and
pantry as more homes double as offices
practicing social distancing from the
fridge has become food for thought and
dietitians say remembering your old
routines can help put off the dreaded
quarantine 19 follow a schedule as if
you are going to the actual office
meaning that you would dress up for work
scheduling breaks in between your
workday big changes in life can often
weigh on us the freshman 15 is a lesson
most college students learn when they're
left to their own devices and while
adults may not be binging on boxed mac
and cheese and 99-cent ramen we are
pushing it to the extreme but well it's
tempting to dip into the treat cupboard
or bake up a storm it could lead to some
regret down the road it becomes more
stressful when it starts affecting our
sleep or when we're waking up and we're
not feeling good about ourselves or our
appearance or our energy levels experts
say getting up and out in a safe manner
even for 20 minutes a day can stop you
from having to pop a new hole in your
belt people need to look at this as a
time to take advantage of and get
themselves into a better place so when
this time expires were able to kind of
jump back into the workforce and you
know the environment that we're used to
being in emotions often run high in
times of stress and that can lead to
unwanted binging and with no certainty
over when this will end there may not be
a rush
to get that summer body but that doesn't
mean we shouldn't practice safe snacks
when does it become too much when it
starts affecting you mentally or
physically a delicate balance of feeding
our need to feel normal without
overindulging Reggie Cecchini Global
News Washington and that is global
national for this Sunday I'm Robin Gill
tonight we leave you with a young man's
sense of humor to keep your spirits up
what is a bug that's hard to understand
what a mumble D that's six yield
Callahan McLaughlin every morning he
sets up a joke stand outside his home
and Saanich BC to provide his neighbors
with a quick quip thank you for watching
good night
[Music]